it was the extraordinary moment the home
of Scotland's former first Minister was
swarming with police
the day Nicholas sturgeon's husband was
detained by detectives investigating SMP
finances ex-chief executive Peter model
later released without charge we
eventually support from the last poll
and it shows that labor has fallen
behind weeks before the Sky News debate
was in full flow as the candidates in
the race to replace sturgeon fought live
on TV the stakes were high
and now this document obtained from
police Scotland shows what was happening
behind the scenes at the time it
suggests officers made a formal request
to prosecutors to search the home of the
former first Minister while the SNP
contest was still going on but crucially
it wasn't given the green light until
Hamza Yusuf was installed as the new
leader and the race was over
the head of Scotland's prosecution
service refused to tell Sky News whether
this was a deliberate delay
did you know about it personally
the crane office and procreator fiscal
service Dorothy being is Scotland's most
senior law officer but also sits in the
Scottish government cabinet as Chief
legal advisor if Bruce comes to shop
we're going to have to have a judge's
latest inquiry we simply cannot have
political interference in the legal and
justice system in Scotland I'm
disappointed that the Lord Advocate
hasn't been quite clear and reputed this
this seems to give legs to the
suggestion that somebody in the Clone
office has slowed down a prosecution or
investigation rather and that is simply
unacceptable
prosecutors say Dorothy Bain has nothing
to do with cases where politicians are
involved but questions are mounting and
the police investigation is not over
Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh